savoir les prévisions du forum
économique mondial l'intelligence
artificielle des technologies devraient
créer 50 8 millions d'emplois à travers
le monde d'ici 2022
les craintes d'un effet négatif de
l'intelligence artificielle sur l'emploi
persiste évidemment on va en parler avec
notre invité les vallées économiste en
chef allié au dm coauteur d'une
publication sur le sujet merci d'être là
monsieur vallée soit on va se situer
d'abord quand on parle d'intelligence
artificielle ça concerne quoi quelle
technologie ça regroupe en fait c'est un
écosystème de technologie des machines
évidemment des ordinateurs une capacité
de traiter des grands nombres de données
on a vu récemment on a parlé de
d'ordinateurs quantiques qui sont
capables d'exécuter beaucoup plus
rapidement des calculs que l'ordinateur
conventionnelle on parle de plusieurs
millions de fois plus rapide ça s'en
vient et aussi le phénomène qu'on
appelle en anglais le big des tonnes la
capacité d'avoir des grosses banques de
données donc ces trois phénomènes à
ensemble en symbiose créée lire le robot
intelligent donc le le robot capable de
s'adapter à des situations
le robot qui apprend qui reçoit des
données et qui change son comportement
donc d'où l'expression de l'intelligence
artificielle et ce qui s' en tout cas
fait peur à certains travailleurs se
demandent s'ils vont perdre leur emploi
être remplacé par un rebond il ya
certaines prévisions qui ont été faites
on regarde un graphique à ce sujet là
qui montrent un bond et des emplois
existants disons la section à gauche
site de vieux emploi plomb les comme ça
qu'ils seraient perdus mais compensé par
un nombre beaucoup plus grand de
nouveaux emplois donc est ce que nous là
il y aura une transition et des gains en
fait il ya des emplois qui existent
aujourd'hui il ya évidemment des emplois
qui vont super dont le sait on les voit
les robots ont remplacé les
téléphonistes par exemple et et ses
emplois qui disparaissent demande donne
lieu à des opportunités à la création de
nouveaux en plastique qui est quand même
assez vieux ont peu reculé jusque là
révolution agricole les jambes et celle
de le terrain
et aujourd'hui ben on les équipe d'un
tracteur est bon il ya des gens il ya
des gens qui ont perdu leur emploi sur
la ferme et d'autres gens qui en ont
gagné plus de 16 employés sont mieux
rémunérés sont plus plaisant sont moins
difficiles sont plus faciles à exécuter
par contre y en a certains qui demandent
des connaissances plus grande donc il
faut vraiment penser en termes de
croissance des connaissances dans un
monde en évolution constante
oui c'est ça vous mentionnez m'en veux
tellement fait que ce sont des
travailleurs ou deux extrêmes de
richesses d'emplois donc les très
qualifiés les moins qualifiés qui vont
profiter de ce virage là pourquoi
évidemment les plus qualifiés on va
avoir une grande demande pour eux on
développe des technologies qui demande
beaucoup de connaissances donc ces gens
là vont être en très grande demande
d'eau solaire va augmenter bon les
locaux vont augmenter leur demande pour
ces gens là vont probablement jamais si
les gens au bas de l'échelle qui ont peu
de qualifications vont pouvoir
travailler ensemble et symbiose avec les
machines donc ces gens là qui ont peu de
connaissances par exemple prenons le
lait fermier qui devient chauffeur de
tracteur c'est pas très long d'apprendre
comment conduire le tracteur api de
faire un gain de productivité énorme
et puis de pouvoir encaisser un salaire
beaucoup plus élevé tout en travaillant
moins fort donc mais les gens au milieu
d'eux alors cesser ces gens là qui dès
qu'ils sont préoccupés qu'exhiber mauger
j'ai appris une connaissance j'ai
développé un talent fou et ce talent le
risque depuis nécessaire la machine
folle va le faire à ma place et je pense
qu'il faut être conscient que ces gens
là vont probablement believe si moins de
sept de ses segments qu'il ya des
solutions à ça dans l'ensemble donc les
prévisions disent qu'on gagnera plus
qu'on y perd mais y aura pas d emplois
qui vont se déplacer aussi par exemple
des gains dans certains pays des pertes
dans d'autres anciens comme elle au
québec au canada
en fait je pense que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans le passé on a
eu ce qu'on appelle off shoring
allégeant elle
l'étranger pour pouvoir bénéficier de
main d'oeuvre qui était moins cher par
exemple on avait peut-être 200 employés
dans une usine s'ils ont ce même si la
bonne à prendre
milan chine comme les salaires sont 40
fois moins élevé on va on va déplacer
lusine anciens vont produire en chine
maintenant le phénomène inverse est en
train de se reproduire avec rapatrier
emploi puisque maintenant cette usine
qui marchait avec 200 employés peut-être
vingt ans peut-être peut fonctionner
avec 20 emplois de travailleurs
qualifiés donc évidemment les gens qui
travaillaient dans l'usiné y avait un
temps hors écuries n'ont pas récupéré
leur job mais il y aura des jobs à
valeur ajoutée qui s'est pas seulement
des emplois qu'on va gagner aussi mais
comme les salaires sont plus élevés il y
aura des taxis seront payés et la
croissance économique se régénérer au
canada plutôt qu'à l'étranger donc tout
sauf pour fonction d'un avis positif je
pense est cet événement venait déjà
quand même un coup saisir âge là tu peux
être lourd pour des pme par exemple est
ce qu'on les aide à franchir ces étapes
là parce que l'étude parle de 2022 le
cédant trois ans et demi oui mais en
fait c'est sur 2000 c'est dans trois ans
il y aura 58 millions d'emplois on
prévoyait faut prendre ça avec un grain
de sel c'est des prévisions mais dans
deux ans en 2030 il y en aura encore
plus donc c'est pas une transition qui
va se faire sur trois ans on donne juste
l'impact sur trois ans de ce qui va se
passer
à très court terme avec l'intelligence
artificielle mais c'est pas un phénomène
à court terme c'est un phénomène qui va
être présent pendant des décennies donc
oui il y aura des coups et est ce que
vous dites est ce qu'on fait quelque
chose mais en fait c'est pas est ce
qu'on fait des choses si mais il faut
faire quelque chose
j'ai pas si on le fait ou on le fait
passer mais il ya nous on propose trois
solutions la première c'est de en fait
que les systèmes éducatifs s'adapte à
cette nouvelle réalité dans toutes les
maisons d'enseignement les maisons
d'enseignement dans les universités et
même des écoles primaires pour enfiler
des compétences qui sont peut-être un
peu différente plutôt que des ombres est
ans techniques qui vont pouvoir être
exécuté par des robots deux autres
réformes en terminant se valent et non
en fait on fait on veut que les
entreprises puissent plus facilement
faire des affaires dont évidemment et il
a aidé la troisième on veut qu'on
encourage entrepreneurship parce que la
création d'entreprise bord
m en tout cas c'est tout un virage est
tout un défi
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler merci
beaucoup merci comme ces vallées